criminal minds was one of the most
successful shows on television during
its 15 seasons on the air
the crime drama produced an astounding
324 episodes in that period of time
which is a huge accomplishment for any
series
for a while there it even seemed like
the saga had finally closed the book but
fans of the cbs radiance masher can rest
assured
knowing that a highly anticipated
revival will be available to stream on
paramount plus in the near future
that means the behavioral analysis unit
still has yet more cases to crack in the
future
and it also means fans will get to spend
more time with all the show's characters
whether they love them or load them
while the show's compelling murder
mysteries are a big part of the appeal
it was always the characters themselves
and their relationships with one another
that gave criminal minds its heart
keeping viewers coming back season after
season some of the protagonists are
beloved fan favorites whose company will
never get old
others meanwhile have made an impact for
the wrong reasons even those played by
famous actors
some of these well-regarded actors may
have some great credits to their name
but fans of criminal minds can be pretty
particular
looking back it appears there was one
specific character who really angered
the fans to the point where they even
petitioned to have a character written
off the series
criminal minds was known for featuring
the occasional big name stars throughout
the years most of whom have been well
received by the show's die-hard audience
that said jennifer love hewitt rubbed
some fans the wrong way despite joining
criminal minds on the back of successful
programs like the ghost whisperer
and movies such as i know what you did
last summer hewitt's character kate
callahan first appeared in the season 10
premiere episode
x presented as a stable motherly figure
with a happy home life albeit with a
tragic past
namely a sister and brother-in-law who
were killed in the pentagon attack on 9
11
she was also given relatable traits such
as an affinity for cute animal photos
and a love of karaoke
karaoke at the benjamin excuse me uh you
were singing karaoke at the benjamin the
night of close
considering that hewitt herself is a
popular actress who often earns fan
adoration in her other work the
producers probably thought that her
character kate was going to be an
instant hit with viewers
it didn't go that way but to be fair the
odds were firmly stacked against her
success from the get-go
when the actress joined the series she
had to fill the void left behind by gene
triplehorn who had played alex blake
critics of the newcomer believe that
developing a new character distracted
from the more important elements of the
series
now kate's warmth and familial ties
certainly earned her some die-hard fans
however those who didn't agree with her
inclusion went to some drastic measures
to try to have her removed
the dissatisfaction with jennifer love
hewitt's character believe it or not
even caused one band to launch a
change.org petition
titled rather straightforwardly write
jennifer love hewitt's character off
criminal minds
claiming that she took away screen time
and distracted from the other agents and
cases in the bau
others explained that they just didn't
like the character and found hewitt's
performance and the writing for her
character to be hokey for what it's
worth that particular petition only
acquired 42 signatures but it
highlighted some of the issues some
viewers had with the new cast member
there are dozens of us dozens
in the end hewitt did depart from the
popular series but not for the reasons
one might expect and not because of the
petition
hewitt did eventually give her critics
their wish leaving criminal minds at the
end of the season in 2015
but it wasn't because of any fan gripes
instead it was because she became
pregnant with her second child
and the due date and her desire to fully
invest her time in the new arrival
conflicted with the time period in which
the show's 11th season was set to start
shooting
speaking to entertainment weekly
criminal minds showrunner erica messer
explained
jennifer wanted to be able to give this
second baby everything she gave her
first
and that's taking time off to be a
full-time mom we wrote to that
and that's how season 10 ends check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one